What's that they see
in a riverful
Firstchech.
What a doche.
What do
she be?
Fore!
Foreign!
Should you not gain your wants, my soul,
then Be not grieved,
but hasten to that banquet which
your Lord's bequath.
And when a thing for which you ask is slow to come,
then know that often through delay
are gifts received.
for
How's everyone? everyone doing
mashallah it's wonderful to be here with you all
I'm just pulling up my uh the Arabic document then we can inshallah
begin shortly
does everyone have uh the
English translation. Has everyone gotten a copy of that?
I don't think I don't see uh copies on the sister's side.
Okay, there's a few.
Okay. Do you Where did Can you tell the person next to you where you got
those?
Cuz I think some some people might not have
uh the printed out copy.
If you don't have the printed out copy, it's also
at the end of the PDF.
So the uh the handout that was uh that was uh
sent as a PDF if you go all the way to the end
it's also there in PDF
uh format. So you're welcome to use
uh either one inshalla.
Okay.
Muhammad Sam.
Alhamdulillah. So, inshallah
in uh this series of classes
uh we're we're going to be looking at this
uh
short treaties
uh short but
very full and meaningful treaties titled
our character.
And this is a book that was written by
uh our teacher
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
bless him and preserve him and allow us to benefit from him.
And he actually wrote this book when he was about 20 years old.
Uh when he was 20 years old, he kind of
uh put these thoughts together
and I think that uh we'll all see how relevant
and
accessible and understandable it is inshallah.
Uh and the book focuses on
three main areas
uh which we'll look at in the coming days inshallah tala.
Our character with Allah,
our character with our own selves
and our character with his creation.
Uh so
uh you'll see when we talk about character in this sense
uh that there's a very deep meaning here and it's not just
you know uh being courteous which is a good thing you know having beautiful is a
good thing
uh but it's much deeper it really is about the way of being
our way of being and our
uh interaction and relationship with Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
our relationship with creation
and our relationship with our own selves.
So the author begins the book with this verse of the Quran.
But whoever desires the hereafter and strives for it accordingly
and is a true believer,
it is they whose striving will be appreciated.
Uh and this verse is hinting to us that the choice selecting this verse is really
helping us understand that this book is going to require spiritual struggle
striving for the
whoever desires the hereafter
and strives for it accordingly
and is a true believer.
It is they whose striving will be appreciated.
In other words, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will reward them generously.
So this book uh despite the fact that it's only a few pages,
it's extremely deep
and it requires each and every one of us
to
really
commit ourselves
to putting into practice what the author is going to advise us.
Okay.
And then he uh after quoting that verse of the Quran,
the author then quotes
a couple lines of poetry.
Do not think that knowledge alone benefits
if one is not crowned by the Lord with good character.
This is really important.
There's a lot of people who might be
knowledgeable,
right? We were I was joking with Mike earlier at the lake
said, "Oh, you know, you've studied."
I haven't really actually studied that much, but he said, "Oh, you've studied a lot now."
said, "Yeah, but it's about putting it into practice.
It's easy to read books.
It's easy to,
you know, uh uh sit in,
but what is really of the utmost importance is putting that knowledge into practice.
And the way that that knowledge manifests when it's put into practice is through beautiful character.
So do not think that knowledge alone benefits if one is not crowned by the Lord
with good character.
When you are granted a praiseworthy trait,
then the distributor of provisions
has truly selected you.
And this is
a line of poetry by Muhammad Hafi.
Okay.
So all of this is just kind of a preamble before coming into the introduction.
So then the author says all praise belongs to Allah,
the generous, the beneficent.
Obviously
in the name of Allah, the all merciful, the most merciful.
All praise belongs to Allah, the generous, the beneficent,
whose benevolence is eternal.
I bear witness that there is no god except Allah, one without partner
in a way befitting of a servant who truly submits to his lordship and who finds
true honor in servitude to him.
I also bear witness that our master, prophet and exemplar, Muhammad sallallah.aihi Wasallam
is the messenger of Allah.
He is the possessor of exalted character, the upright way and the straight path.
And as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in the Quran
that you, oh prophet Muhammad
truly have
mastery
over magnificent character.
And all of the prophets and messengers
they were possessors of
degrees of perfection.
Now when we say that all of the prophets and messengers,
they are the most noble of all of Allah's servants and the most beloved of Allah's
servants.
But even within
their levels of perfection,
there are higher and higher degrees.
And so let's say for example,
you know, the the analogy
always uses is that if someone makes 10 free throws in basketball in a row,
then they have a perfect score, 10 out of 10 free throws.
But if someone makes
20 out of 20 free throws, they still both have 100%,
but one is of a higher degree than the other.
Someone who makes 20 in a row is of a higher degree than someone who's made
10 in a row.
So the prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam
all of the prophets had perfection but the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam had all of good character
each good character trait
and every good character trait to its fullest manifestation.
The prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam had all of good character.
And it's not that he just had
certain degrees of everything.
No, he had everything to the absolute fullest and perfect extent.
This is why Allah says
then the author quotes these lines of poetry from Imad.
He called us to the truth with revelation
given by the all merciful.
the best message.
We answered, accepted, and submitted to his command.
We hear and obey based on guidance and insight.
My Lord, make us steadfast upon guidance and truth.
My Lord, let us die upon the best of religions.
Amen.
Uh, oh Allah, send the greatest blessings and purest peace upon your beloved, our master Muhammad,
and upon his family and companions and all those who follow them with excellence.
And may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala make us among those who follow them with excellence.
A mean.
So all of this is
kind of the introduction to the book and you can see that it relates to good
character and also this commitment
to the very essence of the message that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala revealed to the prophet
Muhammad sallallam.
So then the author says to proceed,
I present within these pages
exalted character and glorious traits
that are the character and traits of a believer who is actualized in the realities of
faith.
Now that's an a very important sentence.
Who is actualized
in the realities of faith?
And the author is going to show us that a lot of people say I'm I'm
Muslim. I'm Muslim
and maybe and this is not
a criticism of any particular individual but this is actually speaking to a superficial understanding of
our religion that people just think that Islam is
what we do in the masid.
Islam is you know prayer.
Islam is
these particular things that are no one is saying are not important
but people just understand them at their most superficial level and they think that it's something
that you can
compartmentalize
and it's just something that you put on you know you you do your bare minimum
and then everything else in life you just live your own way.
But what the author is going to teach us
is that the realities being actualized in faith is something that is absolutely transformative
and that when you have
this relationship with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that permeates your being,
it influences
the way that you smile.
It influences the way that you talk.
It influences the way
what type of husband or wife you are, what type of son or daughter you are,
what type of parent you are,
what type of
employee you are.
It influences your integrity as a person.
It influences
your integrity in private just as much as it does in public
and so forth.
So, we're going to come back to this and I really want us all to think
about
what does it mean to be actualized
in the realities of faith.
Faith
iman
is that which settles in one's heart and is confirmed by one's actions.
So, if someone says, you know, my iman is in my heart, that's beautiful.
Absolutely.
But it needs to translate into your actions.
It's not just something it's between me and God and no one else can interfere.
Yeah, at some extent to some extent that's true,
but it should be something that manifests,
right? Something that is meant to blossom, you know, the the flower when it's it's beautiful
on the inside when the flower is kind of enveloped and wrapped up and then when
it gets to a certain point of maturity and the sun comes out, that beauty comes
out and is manifest.
That's iman. Eman is there
but it should manifest and and
uh that beauty should be expressed.
Amen.
So faith is that which settles in one's heart and is confirmed by one's actions.
It is the removal of blamew worthy traits and the taking on
of virtuous traits.
And really that is the summary of the spiritual path.
The summary of the spiritual path which he here the author is saying is really the
definition of iman itself
is taking on virtuous character and removing
blamew worthy character from our hearts.
Okay.
Noble character
which is you know
noble character has such a sublime and exalted place in Islam that the mission of the
seal of messenger sallallah.aii
wasallam was only to perfect and complete it.
So the prophet sallallah.aihi wasallam who is the seal of messengers.
In other words, he is the culmination
and the fulfillment
of all of
the
missions of the prophets and messengers before him.
And in reality, it's all the same mission.
But he is the culmination of everything that they came with sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And he summarized his mission
as the perfection of noble character.
As we're going to see in this
as he stated,
I was only sent to perfect noble character.
So that teaches us it's very deep.
It's not just,
you know, uh uh smiling at someone or being pleasant.
Someone's nice to you, you're nice to them.
No, it's something that is the actualization
of the realities of iman.
And he's going to teach us inshallah in this book
uh what that looks like and what that means.
Therefore, a believer is bound to give it due consideration
since he will not become actualized in truly following the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
until he takes on the qualities that he was sent to perfect.
So it requires this deep commitment.
Okay. What are the qualities?
What are the what is the character that you, oh messenger of Allah
were sent to perfect?
And there are beautiful character traits that you know are easy for us to be attracted
to. But then there are other noble character traits that
contain the heat of spiritual purification
and that require mujah
requires struggle
and it requires that you fight against your nefs
and it requires that you actually look deep within yourself.
For those who were here this morning
uh at the reflection session after
sometimes
for a lot of us
even having
five minutes of silence
can be extremely uncomfortable.
So you're like I have to
I have to think
I have to
organize my thoughts.
And many people actually chase distractions
and in the most extreme forms, they'll even
give into addictive behaviors or maybe not give into addictive behaviors, but become caught up in
addictive behaviors because they're running away from
being with themselves and feeling
what it is that they're going through.
But that's essential for us to grow.
And I remember one of our teachers,
he said that it requires a great amount of courage
to look inside of yourself and to see what's really going on.
So he says that you will not become actualized
in truly following the prophet until you take on the qualities he was sent to perfect.
And that requires a lot of introspection.
It requires a lot of thought and consideration.
This is the very basis of our eminence
and pillar of our advancement
is noble character.
Is noble character.
And one of the students of Imam Malik,
one of the great imams of Islam,
he said, I spent 20 years studying with Malik.
And he said 18 of those years
I focused on his
I focused on his state with Allah.
And then two of those years
I spent focused on
taking from his outward knowledge his knowledge of
his knowledge of hadith and so forth.
And then he said,"I wish
I spent those two years taking from his and
because outward knowledge there's a lot of people who
are very knowledgeable
and who might have access might be people of fatwa and people of technical sciences and
which is extremely important don't get me wrong
but where are you going to find
the state with Allah that Malik had
that's rare.
That's rarer
than that other kind of knowledge.
Where do you find someone whose very way of being
resembles so closely that of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that merely being in their presence
is a lesson in and of itself before they even speak.
Being in their presence
brings your heart closer to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this is why there were some of the sahab
they became Muslim by merely seeing the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Eman entered their heart just by seeing him or sometimes by very brief interactions with him.
One of the stories of
the head of the tribe of
Do
the tribe that Abu
was from. He was the head of his tribe
and he came to Mecca
because he was from outside of Mecca
and he spent time sitting with the other nobles of Quraysh because they're all kind of
tribal
uh dignitaries and so forth.
So the whole night
they were talking to him about the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Don't you dare listen to one word this man says.
If you even talk to him one time he's going to put a spell on you
and this that and the other.
He said the whole night they got me really scared.
Then they were giving people like cotton and things that they put in their ears.
If you if you see him put this in your ears don't let him even speak
to you.
So then he said the next day I went to the Kaa and I saw the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and I put the stuff in my ears and
and he said and he was praying there
and he was making dua or whatever it might might have been that in that particular
time the prophet was doing
and he said to himself he said listen
I've come across some
magicians and people who do kind of sorcery and slight of hand and even
you get a very negative feeling.
Those people, they have a a way about them that is very dark
and and it's like toxic for your soul.
So he saw the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam praying there at the
worshiping Allah
said this is beautiful.
He said I'm an intelligent person.
I can differentiate between
right and wrong and truth and falsehood and what is good speech and what is sorcery.
So he took the things out and he said, "Teach me a little bit of what
you have." So the prophet wasallam came and he said, "Come sit with me."
And he taught him.
He just recited the suras of Quran that we all know and learn as as children.
Immediately became Muslim.
brief interactions with the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
These are people
and his inheritors sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
They're people who
true good character
is something that is etched into their very being.
Most of us and it's this is how we're all works in progress.
Most of us try to
act
on good character which is good
but for them it's something that's already part of the fabric of their being.
It's deeply embedded.
I remember I was with one of our teachers
from Mecca
and this is actually in in uh in Miss Saga in Toronto
and he gave this at a masid and he's you know a visiting scholar
from Mecca
this beautiful man
from the city of the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam a descendant of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and it was a beautiful
when the they were introducing him they mentioned some of his teachers and so forth
and someone in the crowd
was just like, "Oh, you know, these people are
Sufis,"
you know, and it was just like, "Here we go."
Right? And and a lot of it is and and if you're a person who's heard
this word in a negative connotation, please feel free to come and talk to us.
We'll clarify. I remember someone said it to He's like, "Hey man, people are saying you're
a He like looked around like it was like the worst word in the Sufi."
And I was like, "Okay."
And he was like, "No, man.
You're meant to be more offended.
Like you should be I was like, "What does that mean to you?"
So like people who worship graves and stuff, I'm like, "I don't worship graves, so I'm
not worried about it."
But a lot of people, they have this negative connotation when they hear that.
Anyway, so there was someone in the crowd there who as soon as he heard who
he had studied with, he's like, "Oh, these are some Sufis, man."
So he came up
and he was like, "Please
uh tell everyone in the
masid that this person's a Sufi and these are bad people."
I was like,
"This is a fellow Muslim from
he's a vis just have the basic decency to say, "Thank you very much for coming."
And then someone else came up to him.
He was like, "What are you doing about the king over there and what's going on
politically and this that the other and are you speaking out?"
And then he said to him, he said,
"This is like politics.
That's better if we talk about it outside of the masid.
Let's talk about Allah and his messenger here in the masid."
And then the man just kept kind of berating him.
And I'm like, "This person's a guest.
Like, what's wrong with you people?"
And I was so upset at how they had mistreated him.
and he saw that I was, you know, visibly
bothered. He said, "What's wrong?"
I'm like, "Habib, look at how they're talking to you.
People coming up to you as if you're responsible for what's going on in Saudi Arabia
or people say like," and he was like, "The prophet sallall alaihi wasallam went through much
worse."
He was totally cool.
Like he was not bothered in the least.
He said the prophet went through much worse.
Like what? Don't be don't sweat it.
And it was like, I'm trying to learn
how to have that character that comes
much more naturally to you.
And as I imazali says, that's real good character.
There might be someone who gives a lot of money.
So people say he's generous, but he's not actually generous.
And there might be someone who is generous of spirit who has nothing to give,
but they're actually a generous person.
That's real good character.
And this is what the author is telling us
that we have to dig deep
and work on our hearts and souls
to
actualize our iman so that even if it doesn't come naturally to us now
that it eventually eventually will come naturally to us inshallah tala.
And then he says here
this is the very basis
of our eminence
and it is the pillar of our advancement.
Now, that's an extremely important sentence
because a lot of us as Muslims, particularly in
a postc colonial world,
and he's actually going to speak to this very directly
in a postc colonial world, a lot of people, whether we know it or not,
we're still
experiencing
the aftermath
of
many Muslim Muslim countries, even if we're converts and maybe we're not from Muslim majority lands,
that's a separate point.
But we're still as an ummah
experiencing the aftermath
of
when many Muslim countries were colonized.
And even if we're from countries that are not Muslim majority, but they've been colonized, we
can still understand
some of the aftermath of what that did to people's sense of identity,
people's sense of value and worth
where maybe the language was changed.
Maybe people started to think we're backwards and they're advanced.
We don't really have progress.
And in the 20th century, particularly in the last century,
a lot of
Muslim scholarly discourse
was centered around
how we
come back
from
this
suffering that the ummah experienced and is still experiencing in a very real way,
in a in a kind of different way,
but experienced
by being colonized
and defeated
and even being in some ways intellectually and spiritually broken.
How do we come back from that?
So many people say no, we have to be politically like them.
We have to be economically like the western powers and the post-enlightenment powers.
We have to be in terms of our technology and education and so forth.
A lot of people will internalize
no no you know what
we are backwards.
And what the author is saying here and it's extremely powerful
is that
the very
basis
of our eminence
of
our
ascendancy
our elevation. not elevating ourselves over others
but actually being elevated in the sight of God.
And
the
and the pillar
of our advancement and revival
comes from good character.
And someone might say, "Oh man, that sounds like very
nice language and flowery
kind of, you know, it sounds nice,
but how's that really going to translate into the world
when you see
what's going on with the ummah?"
We're going to look at that shortly, inshallah.
Keep that question in mind.
We'll look at it shortly.
But he's going to back up
this
uh understanding
okay that the basis of our eminence and the pillar of our advancement is in our
character and I'll tell you a story of one of those sahab it's one of the
most amazing stories
and
we need to study their lives because if you look at the umah today
the odds were even greater against them.
If you look at the battle of Bedr,
you look at the battle of, you look at the battle of the trench,
the odds were not in their favor outwardly.
But look at how in a short period of time
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala brought about the greatest amount of change
and the spread of Islam in this very short amount of time
particularly compared to other periods of history and other movements and so forth.
There's something miraculous
and that's why even
western thinkers will say that the most influential human being in in human history trying to
look at it from an objective lens is the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
We already know that
but even other people from the outside recognize that because it's nothing short of
miraculous.
And when you look at the
the character of the
you see it
one of the
his name escapes me now but he was captured by the disbelievers
and essentially
they kept him captive
and eventually executed him
and the Meccans uh uh captured him
and while they captured him
they
uh
they he had asked for a knife, which is essentially a razor
to
uh groom himself
and and
uh take care of his cleanliness
and groom himself properly.
And scholars say why was he grooming himself if he was going to be executed?
Because he wanted to beautify himself for his meeting with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Like even just to think about
the state of someone's spirit
who is able to do that in that moment.
They're amazing people.
It's easy to talk about it, but he was living it.
So they brought him a knife.
He said, "I want to, you know, you've had me captive for a while.
I want to
uh trim my and and groom myself."
So they brought him a knife.
While he had the knife, one of their children, the children of the people who had
held him captive and are about to execute him, one of the children was playing and
came into his lap.
So, one of the women
saw that child in his lap and he's got this knife.
So, he looked at her completely calmly.
He said, "Are you scared?"
He said, "Us,
the companions of Muhammad were never treacherous.
Your child is safe with me.
I would never harm your child."
Said, "We companions of Muhammad
were not treacherous."
That woman
who saw that and witnessed that eventually became Muslim.
And she says, "I never saw anything more beautiful than the day that I saw him
grooming himself and when he had that knife before he was executed."
He said, "Us, the companions of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam, we do not we're never treacherous.
We would not harm a child.
We would not do that to someone innocent."
And they executed him.
But what does that tell you
about the deep level of He could have said, "Okay, you got to let me go,
right?" Like the movies.
I'm just trying to get out of here.
No, no, no.
There's a a standard.
There is a level
of
that we hold to the no matter what, no matter how anyone else treats us, we
do not go below that standard.
So then the author quotes this line of uh poetry
which is a line of poetry by a contemporary Arab poet Ahmed
peoples. You could even say
are peoples or civilizations
or communities.
Peoples
are nothing other than their character.
If their character is lost,
then they too are lost.
And that's really powerful
because what makes a civilization
I mean even the word civility being civil
is part of civilization.
Civilization is not just military might.
And even in this very country, you had people at the highest levels
of
presidency and and political power who were trying to fight against the military industrial complex
that they realized you're trying to make the military into something that is an economic benefit.
You have an economic interest in war.
That's not what military power is meant to be used for.
So there was a loss of integrity.
And there were people who were trying to within our own government at a time that
were trying to fight against those forces
because they realized
power is not what makes a civilization great.
Military strength, it's important.
It's a part of,
you know, what makes a a a civilization.
and so forth.
But it's not everything.
You know, you have all of these people weapons of mass destruction and so forth in
the hands of people
who are not great people.
So what is it that makes a civilization?
It's their character.
It's their integrity.
It's their work ethic.
It's their trustworthiness.
It's their honesty.
The prophet Muhammad Sam
years before he ever even received revelation was known in Mecca
as
truthful and trustworthy.
That's what they would call him al
the trustworthy one.
They knew him by that quality and it was so
firmly
uh understood and experienced by the Meccans that even people who didn't believe in his message
would give their most valuable
uh possessions
when they would travel they would entrust it to the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
You know, when you travel back in the day, people didn't have, you know, security deposit
boxes and banks and things of that nature.
So, they had to have people that they trusted.
They say, "This is
a big pouch of gold.
I need to leave it with someone.
I can't travel with it."
Who's not going to skim off the top,
you know? It's a big pouch of gold.
Someone just take a couple coins off the top.
The guy's not going to notice.
So you need to keep it with someone who even if you would never notice they
have such a degree of trustworthiness that they would never take something away from you.
That was the prophet Muhammad wasallam for the Meccans
years before even receiving revelation.
Why?
Because it's of the utmost importance
that that character that integrity
precedes the message.
As we say in in in
you know our societies, talk is cheap.
And as we're going to even look at when we educate children, children learn through their
eyes more than they learn through their ears.
Do what I say, not as I do.
Now, children are going to follow what you do.
As our people, they're going to judge your integrity based on
your character.
Peoples are nothing other than their character.
If their character is lost, then they too are lost.
I remember someone uh a scholar commenting on
visiting one of the great
uh the great bastions of Islam in Sham.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala inshallah restore Sham and Yemen to their full glory and benefit
for the ummah and all of the lands in the east and west.
But he once went to the marketplace and the marketplace is a very good place to
gauge
integrity.
So he went to the marketplace and he was going to buy from, you know, a
vendor who was selling fruit or nuts or something of that nature.
So he was about to buy from him and the man said, "You know what?
I've sold enough today.
Go to my friend over there."
His friend is actually what we would call a competitor.
Go to him over there.
he didn't sell as much today.
Go buy fruits from him.
And he said, "Mashallah."
That's a level of integrity where someone's able to say, "You know what?
Alhamdulillah,
Allah has blessed me today.
I've made more than enough.
My my brother over there hasn't sold as much.
Go buy something from him."
He said, "Alhamdulillah, the ummah is in a good state."
He said, "I came years later and I was about to buy from someone."
And the competitor yells from across the way goes, "His goods, his fruits are no good.
Come over here.
I got the good stuff."
He said, "Ah, something changed."
Peoples,
the good, the benefit, the success, the advancement of a people's
is in their character.
When that's lost,
then all of the infrastructure and all of the economic power and all of the milit
that all just crumbles.
And this is why
we have an extremely
important
job to do
in this country and beyond.
But we're here.
We're residents of, you know, the United States and Canada.
And maybe people have come from other places as well.
Wherever Allah has placed us, we have a responsibility to the land and to the people.
I remember one of our teachersh
was saying to
and I happen to
be fortunate enough to be in the room and hear this advice.
He said, "When you teach people about Islam in America,
teach them Islam in a way
that
shows that it is a restoration
of their values.
It's not
something foreign and alien that you're bringing in from the outside, but you're actually taking part
in restoring
the good values
that might have been more prevalent not so long ago.
Where people used to say things like sir and ma'am
to their elders.
Where people would say things like please and thank you.
where people had
respect for one another, where people
were could could trust each other more.
There's been a breakdown.
Everyone is in their own little island.
That Islam is actually a restoration
of the good things that used to be
more prominent in society.
And that's the job that we have to do.
And that's why
uh restoring character
is of the utmost importance for all of us.
We'll continue looking at the author's words inshallah tala.
So then he says,
I compiled these noble character traits and exalted qualities and listed them so that they may
serve as a reminder of what we must expect from each other
come together for
and cooperate in.
In other words, that we have a
collective
consciousness at the level of our umah that we have a job to do, that we
have a standard to live by
and that it's not just something a few people do, but we all want we want
to
be elevated in the sight of Allah and we want others to rise up
and be dignified and elevated as well.
Each of these character traits can be explained in great detail and there are many Quranic
verses and noble hadiths that emphasize these traits.
Our goal here as mentioned is only to remind.
Perhaps there will be an opportunity in the future to speak in more detail regarding each
trait.
After first strengthening their belief,
Muslims today are in dire need of holding firmly to these noble
character traits,
values, and ideals
which are uh which are also sorry uh oh no actually
uh
is it wi is or are
we'll get back to that if anyone knows which is also
uh a means for strengthening belief.
And by the way, for those of you who this is a rough draft as you
can see
uh inshallah we'll continue to refine it until it's uh suitable for for publication inshallah tala.
So
uh we are in dire Muslims today are in dire need of holding firmly to these
noble character traits, values and ideals which is also the means for strengthening belief.
So what the author is saying here
is that we need the first and most important thing we need to do is strengthen
our iman
is strengthen our iman.
And that's actually what we focused on today
uh in the reflection session this morning is reflecting on
marvels of Allah's creation
and the wonders
in his beautiful design
that allows us to grow in iman
and see the wisdom that Allah has placed within
the creation that all point towards him subhanahu wa ta'ala
and when we strengthen our im
we become
more like
the the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam infused them
with the highest degrees of faith and certitude
such that you see many examples of the Sahabah even when they faced something as
jarring as death
they were not perturbed
which is
a very high level of faith there's a natural degree where a person is
does not like
you know the the the
does not like death.
We're not morbid.
We don't have this fascination and obsession with death.
But they realized that it is a step in the journey and it is a step
closer to the beloved.
So when it came
they were not shaken by that and that was due to their iman.
Okay. After strengthening iman, Muslims today are in dire need of holding firmly to these noble
character traits. And they're also they have this sort of uh mutually reinforcing way of strengthening
iman as well.
Regardless of whether one is a scholar,
craftsman,
ruler,
trader, or worker, each needs to apply these character traits in his dealings with his Lord,
companions, and himself.
And those are actually the breakdowns of the chapters.
Our character with Allah,
our character with his creation, and our character with our own selves.
Indeed, we have suffered much harm
by losing these noble character traits to divisiveness and animosity.
And we have experienced many woes
because we abandon them.
You see that the vast majority of Muslims today
neglect the rights of others,
are rigid in their views,
arrogant, and corrupt in their dealings.
There is no power nor ability saved by Allah, the exalted, the Almighty.
We know with certainty that without coming together,
cooperating and uniting,
we will not be able to resist our enemies nor achieve any victory.
And this is uh and we'll end with this inshallah
and pick up tomorrow from this point.
But this is what is interesting about
the author's
scope of concern.
He wrote this when he was 20 years old.
He wrote this in
of the Hijidi
uh calendar. We're now in 1447.
So that's what 44 years ago.
Is my math right?
44 years ago
when he was 20 years.
No. Am I right?
Yeah. Subhan Allah.
Okay. So 44 years ago when he's 20 years old
and he has this concern at the level of the umah
at the level of the entire um and he's actually talking about and as
the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam informed us
that at in every century Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will bring forth
someone who revives the rei the the religion of Islam for the ummah.
And he at 20 years old is already concerned
about bringing around
a level of revival
of this entire dean and of the realities of iman
at the level of the entire ummah.
He could have spoken just about Yemen.
He could have spoken just about his local.
He could have spoken about Arabspeaking countries in the Middle East, but he's actually talking about
the entire
um
and that for us
to be able to resist our enemies and to have
this revival
and to have
uh this
reawakening,
we need to understand
at the deepest levels.
So the scope of what we're talking about might actually seem that we're just talking about
good character
which seems to be
very nice
and maybe something that's seen as
secondary or tertiary.
But what the author is saying is no
this is at the very foundation
of what benefits the entire ummah
and which is the core
message
of the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam's mission. So we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to allow us to benefit
uh from these character traits that he's going to
uh share with us that Allah subhana wa tala allows us to have that level
of determination
and courage
and commitment where we put this knowledge into practice
in such a way that the realities of faith
become manifest
at a level where we become
servants of the entire um and servants of everyone in creation.
Alhamdulillah.
We'll stir them.